meine Mutter hat sich immer gewünscht
dass ich Lehrer werden sollte ich habe
ihr dann gesagt du ich will mal
Millionär werden
jetzt ein bisschen die Frage wessen
Staat ist es es ist eben der Staat der
Reichen Deutschland der Staat der
Reichen klingt erstmal krass und
irgendwie auch krass übertrieben aber
wenn man sich einfach nur die nackten
Zahlen anschaut sieht man wir sind Platz
3 auf der Rangliste der Länder mit den
meisten Millionärinnen und das trotz
Pandemie Krieg in der Ukraine und
heftiger Inflation manche sagen das sei
nicht gerecht und fordern radikale
Umverteilung dazu gehören teilweise auch
die um die es geht wie die Millionen
Erbin Marlene Engelhorn die
steuerprügeligen die meine Klasse
genießt sind echt welche die man abbauen
muss kann man so sehen andere aber
finden dass die die viel haben das auch
verdient haben und sowieso schon richtig
hohe Steuern zahlen auf der anderen
Seite dürfen aber auch nicht diejenigen
vergessen werden die von den Ergebnissen
ihrer Schaffenskraft viel abgeben um den
sozialen Frieden in unserem Land zu
erhalten wie ihr seht viel Stoff für
jede Menge Debatte und die schauen wir
uns in dieser Folge genauer an wir
fragen uns warum werden reiche
eigentlich immer reicher was könnte
dagegen getan werden und warum wäre das
vielleicht gar nicht mal so gerecht hi
ich bin Lana grosse und das hier ist
Kontext und wenn man sich auf die Zahlen
und Fakten stützt dann sieht man in der
Tat des Deutschland den letzten 20 25
Jahren deutlich ungleicher geworden ist
und das zeigt sich besonders deutlich
beim Vermögen hier seht ihr wie das in
Deutschland verteilt ist und ihr seht
auch dass eine Hälfte der Bevölkerung
gerade mal etwas mehr als ein Prozent
besitzt die reichsten 10%, aber mehr als
zwei Drittel aber was bedeutet
eigentlich Reich einen echten Grenzwert
gibt es nicht wer in Deutschland aber
mehr als
477.000 € besitzt gehört zu den
reichsten 10 %. und werden Vermögen von
000 € besitzt gehört zu den reichsten 5
%. und auch die Krisen der vergangenen
Jahre haben die Superreichen wenige hart
getroffen von dem gesamten neuen
Vermögen das 2020 und 2021 in
Deutschland erwirtschaftet wurde gegen
81 Prozent an das reichste Prozent auf
das Konto der restlichen 99% gegen
dagegen nur 19%. es ist wirklich so dass
ich zum 20 mittlerweile sagen kann okay
Obst und Gemüse ist nicht mehr sondern
halt nur noch
harte Lebensmittel also wie Nudeln das
macht mich sorgen und Angst da sieht
jetzt nicht mehr bezahlen kann es wird
für diese Familien deutlicher spürbar
dass sie quasi abgehängt sind und dass
sie nicht auf dem Schirm sind von
politischen Maßnahmen ist das gerecht
nein sagt eine deutliche Mehrheit der
Deutschen 62% der Befragten beurteilten
die soziale Gerechtigkeit bei einer
Umfrage Mitte Juli als ungerecht oder
sogar sehr ungerecht aber woran liegt
das unter anderem daran dass die die
viel haben auch die Möglichkeit haben
ihr Geld für sich arbeiten zu lassen
also durch Zinsen Aktiengewinne oder
Wertsteigerungen von Immobilien
durch viel harter Arbeit
reich werden durch Arbeit für
Normalverdiener eher eine Illusion ein
Grund dafür Gewinne aus Vermögen werden
geringer besteuert als Einkommen oder
anders gesagt wenn Geld arbeitet lohnt
sich das Meer als wenn Menschen arbeiten
zu Wahrheit gehört aber auch während die
durchschnittliche Wochenarbeitszeit bei
39 Stunden liegt gaben reiche Menschen
in einer Befragung an im Schnitt 48
Stunden zu arbeiten es gibt natürlich
theoretisch die Möglichkeit Vermögen in
der Gesellschaft umzuverteilen zum
Beispiel mit einer Vermögenssteuer die
fällt auf alles an was jemand besitzt
Geld aber auch Immobilien oder
Unternehmen oft verbunden mit einem
hohen Freibetrag in Deutschland wird
aber keine Vermögenssteuer erhoben
zumindest heute nicht denn das war mal
anders von 1923 bis 1996 zeigten
vermögende eine Steuer von unter einem
Prozent also auch nicht so viel 1995
aber die derzeitige Erbschaft und
Vermögenssteuer auf Grundvermögen ist
verfassungswidrig zur Begründung verwies
das Bundesverfassungsgericht darauf dass
Immobilien bislang durch zu niedrige
Einheitswerte steuerlich geringer
belastet worden sein als etwa Geld und
Aktienvermögen doch anstatt Immobilien
neu zu bewerten entschlossen sich FDP
und Union dazu die Vermögensteuer
auszusetzen abgeschafft wurde sie
allerdings nie und alle paar Jahre
ploppt diese Diskussion wieder auf und
wie steht es mit der Vermögenssteuer
soll die zurückkehren ich glaube dass
das angemessen ist und dass dagegen auch
vernünftige Einwände nicht möglich sind
die Vermögenssteuer wird es mit uns
nicht geben überall gibt es höhere
Vermögensbesteuerung als in Deutschland
und deshalb kann es auch nicht falsch
sein wenn wir das wieder einführen was
wir schon mal hatten auch eine Mehrheit
der Befragten gab zuletzt in einer
Umfrage der Bertelsmann Stiftung an für
eine stärkere Besteuerung von Reichen zu
sein Gegner in argumentieren ich würde
es nicht gerecht finden wenn wir eine
Vermögenssteuer einführen und zwar
deswegen weil Menschen die ein Vermögen
haben sich das irgendwann mal gerichtet
haben und aufgebaut haben Vermögen höher
zu besteuern ist in Deutschland
kontraproduktiv weil es einfach ganz oft
eben Familienunternehmer trifft wo das
Vermögen in den Betrieben gebunden ist
außerdem wäre die Bewertung von Vermögen
kompliziert Immobilien Kunstgegenstände
und Schmuck müssen begutachtet und
regelmäßig neu bewertet werden und das
ist teuer allein dadurch würden
Einnahmen aus der Vermögensteuer um 20%
sinken und trotzdem schätzungen zufolge
würde sie zwischen 10 und 20 Milliarden
Euro pro Jahr einbringen doch Besitz
lässt sich auch anders umverteilen
nämlich mit einer Erbschaftssteuer also
wir finden in unserem Studien das
ungefähr ein Drittel des Vermögens nicht
erarbeitet sondern ein erbt ist und dann
habe ich halt eine
Vermögenskonzentration am oberen Ende
die einfach mit der anfangsausstattung
zu tun hatte mit dem Glück was die
Person hatten und dieses Glück lässt
sich beziffern bis zu 400 Milliarden
Euro werden pro Jahr in Deutschland
verschenkt oder vererbt seine Studien
davon sind 2021 aber nur rund 9
Milliarden Euro in der Staatskasse
gelandet also ungefähr
2%. das führt auch dazu dass gerade bei
hochvermögen Ausnahmen gemacht werden
und dazu dass am Ende des Tages ein
Mensch der raucht mehr in den deutschen
Haushalt einzahlt als ein Mensch mit
Vermögen dass die Einnahmen aus der
Erbschaftssteuer so gering sind hat
verschiedene Gründe eine große Rolle
spielt aber dass es viele Ausnahmen gibt
und von denen profitieren am
allermeisten besonders vermögende
Familien wir sehen tatsächlich die
Steuerquote jenseits von 26 Millionen
Euro also weit weit über ihrem
Unternehmen die liegt bei 1% und
teilweise drunter also es kann
tatsächlich 10 Milliarden Euro
weitergegeben werden und es fällt
tatsächlich null Euro Steuern geht das
klingt irgendwie absolut so absolut dass
sogar eine Superreiche selbst fordern
mehr Steuern zahlen zu müssen so auch
die unterstütze in der Initiative Text
hinaus wir wünschen uns die Aufhebung
der Ausnahmen bei Erbschaft und
Schenkungssteuer wir wünschen uns eine
offene Diskussion über eine
Vermögensabgabe wir wünschen muss eine
progressive Besteuerung bei
Kapitalerträgen halten wir fest man
könnte Vermögen und Erbe stärker
besteuern und so Geld in der
Gesellschaft umverteilen wenn man das
denn möchte aber was ist mit dem
Einkommen seit Jahren geht die Schere
zwischen denen die ganz oben und denen
die unten verdienen weiter auseinander
die sogenannte manager to worker pay
ratio ist von 2005 bis 2017 von 42 auf
71 gestiegen das heißt Dax-Vorstände
verdienten 2017 etwa 71 mal so viel wie
ihre Angestellten Problem was war
überall haben wird nicht nach Qualität
und nach Leistung bezahlt ne also solche
Leute auch noch die Hand aufhalten die
haben genügend Schaden in der
Volkswirtschaft angerichtet und auch
viele Menschen ist Unglück geritten ich
kann es immer nachvollziehen diese
Summen die die alle verlangen und
bekommen und das ist äh das übersteigt
man Horizont was diese Stimmen zeigen es
gibt ein Gefühl der Ungerechtigkeit beim
Thema entlohn und auch hier könnte man
ansetzen
zum Beispiel mit einer Erhöhung des
Spitzensteuersatzes aktuell liegt der
bei 42%. zahlen müssen in Personen die
rund 63.000 Euro und mehr im Jahr
verdienen die sogenannte Reichensteuer
beträgt 45% und fällt ab einem
Jahreseinkommen von etwa 278.000 Euro an
die Wirtschaftsweisen wollen besser
verdienende zur Kasse bitten durch einen
energiesoli oder durch die Erhöhung des
Spitzensteuersatzes das interessante
topverdienende haben früher in
Deutschland viel mehr Steuern gezahlt
als heute der 56% Spitzensteuersatz
bleibt unverrückbarer Eckpfeiler
sozialdemokratischer Steuerpolitik dazu
noch eine 5%ige Ergänzungsabgabe die
schon steuerpflichtige Einkommen von
mehr als 60.000 bzw 120.000 D-Mark
Treffen soll
dieser unverrückbare Spitzensteuersatz
wurde dann 1990 von Schwarz-Gelb auf 53%
gesenkt die stufenweise Ablenkung auf
die bis heute gültigen 42 Prozent wurde
aber erst 2001 beschlossen ausgerechnet
von einer SPD-geführten Regierung unter
Kanzler Schröder wer das blockiert etwa
im Bundesrat wie Unionsleute ankündigen
der vergeht sich am Wachstum der
Volkswirtschaft und der bekämpft nicht
Arbeitslosigkeit sondern der trägt dazu
bei dass sie schwerer zu bekämpfen ist
trotz der Absenkung zählt Deutschland im
internationalen Vergleich zu den
hochsteuernländern der Höchststeuersatz
liegt bei 45% und damit beispielsweise
deutlich über dem EU-Durchschnitt von
37,77%. klar ist würde man die Steuern
für vermögende und gut verdienende
erhöhen wäre mehr Geld für Bildung
Gesundheit Verkehr oder Sicherheit da
das sagen nicht nur die
Wirtschaftsweisen sondern auch linke SPD
und Grüne und selbst die CDU hat vor
kurzem eine Erhöhung des
Spitzensteuersatzes vorgeschlagen
einzige Ausnahme die FDP Bundesregierung
beabsichtigt keine Steuern zu erhöhen
man kann ja nicht sagen wir wollen
Infrastruktur keine Steuern erhöhen bei
der Schuldenbremse nichts machen und
deswegen müssen wir meiner Auffassung
nach auch eben die sehr hohen Einkommen
die wirklich sehr sehr hohen Einkommen
und die sehr hohen Vermögen stärker
belasten die Position innerhalb der
Ampel liegen also super weit auseinander
gleichzeitig wächst die Ungleichheit und
das kann langfristig zum Problem werden
auch für die Demokratie Menschen die
wirtschaftlich abgehängt sind also in
relative Einkommensarmut leben werden
sich tendenziell weniger an Wahlen etwa
beteiligen am gesellschaftlichen Leben
beteiligen was denkt ihr über die
Vermögensverteilung in Deutschland
sollte sich
daran erinnern oder ist es gerecht so
wie es ist schreibt es mir gerne in die
Kommentare und auch gerne den Kanal
abonnieren wenn ihr mehr von Kontext
sehen wollt schaut gerne diese Folge an
bei der wir die Inflation in den Kontext
gesetzt haben und wenn Ihr noch mehr
über Vermögensverteilung wissen wollt
dann empfehle ich euch dieses Video